wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
wenn nico raecke hier kein spanisch wie
gewünscht kommentiert fliegen zurück
nach spanien
nein ich komme nicht mit ich bleibe hier
in deutschland
ich bin extra aus münchen gekommen
zuerst wollte ich fliegen aber der flug
ist ausgefallen
da musste ich mit dem bus hierher fahren
und konnte unterwegs nicht schlafen
ich bin ziemlich müde also bitte lasst
uns einfach gehen nein du kannst gerne
gehen ich habe schon mit papa
telefoniert ich glaube du verstehst es
nicht papa hat mir gesagt dass ich dich
zurückholen soll
wahrscheinlich geht der nächste flug
morgen vormittag über madrid oder
barcelona nach zivil also also guten
flug zu mir ist das völlig egal was du
machst aber unsere eltern machen sich
sorgen
du machst mir mein problem nico ich
bitte sie jetzt zu gehen erklären dass
morgen
pforzheim brust